c'est l'un des pires cauchemars des
cyclistes une seconde d'inattention la
portière de l'automobile qui s'ouvre et
baigne on frappe un mur les
emporterrages en fait c'est la crainte
numéro un du cycliste en milieu urbain
c'est cette crainte là de voir une
portière s'ouvrir devant soi et de ne
rien pouvoir faire pour l'éviter
seulement à Montréal on rapporte un
moyen de trois en portières par semaine
et plus de 1100 depuis 10 ans c'est pas
prévisible est fermé port est ouverte
elle a besoin que des amis que je
connais qui font beaucoup de vélo c'est
toujours une pensée les passagers
surtout n'ont pas le réflexe de regarder
le rétro donc ça c'est quelque chose
faut vraiment faire attention mais
depuis l'automne dernier les écoles
enseignent nous apprentis conducteurs
comment ouvrir le porte de façon
beaucoup plus sécuritaire pour les
cyclistes avec la méthode que tout le
monde se sert aujourd'hui c'est toujours
la main gauche on va chercher la
portière en eau puis ah non fait qu'on
ferme la porte ou des fois c'est on trop
tard puis cycliste il fait des culbuts
l'idée c'est simplement de changer de
main pour arriver mes résultats
maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on va faire
c'est que garder la main sur le volant
on va prendre la main droite on va ici
chercher la main puis en faisant ça le
corps il tourne en automatiquement on
voit l'anglement on fait qu'on a même
pas commencé à ouvrir la porte hier
pourquoi on regarde l'anglement puis on
voit le danger arriver si on a la droite
au lieu de la gauche c'est plus facile à
dire qu'à faire lorsque vous montrez ça
a pas de l'être tellement naturel ça
l'est pas puis mesure comme vous - même
aussi j'ai de la misère à le faire dans
ma propre auto là mais il faut pratiquer
pour le faire éventuellement pour que ça
soit naturel comme la ceinture cette
technique peut sauver des vies 10 vélos
Québec mais il faudra faire encore plus
tant qu'on aura des bandes Cyclades qui
longe les autosassionnés et bien on met
les cyclistes à risque il faut donc
vraiment prévoir une mise à niveau de
nos infrastructures cyclables pour
qu'elle soit physiquement séparées de la
circulation
Montréal